Why Don't Trains Have Cabooses Anymore?
For well over a century, cabooses, the cute
quintessentially red cars at the rear of trains
in years past, served an integral function
in train operations.
Carrying a brakeman and a flagman back when
brakes were set by hand, when it was time
to slow the train, the engineer would blow
the whistle.
This signaled to the brakemen, and one would
emerge from the caboose and work his way toward
the engine, while another would leave the
engine and work his way back toward the caboose.
At each car, the brakemen would stop and turn
its brakewheel with a club.
Once the train stopped, the flagman would
leave the caboose with a flag, lantern or
other visual display and walk back down the
track to warn any approaching trains.
The caboose was also an office for the conductor,
who was responsible for managing the paperwork
that accompanied each freight car.
Often assigned to a particular man, the interiors
of cabooses would be equipped as temporary
living quarters, and even decorated with personal
items like photos and curtains.
Considered a home away from home, crews would
sometimes sleep in the cabooses, and many
conductors even prepared meals in them.
Legend has it, the cupola on top of the caboose
was invented by a conductor who used to stack
boxes up, sit on them, and look through a
hole in the roof of his car.
Regardless of its true origins, after about
1863, the cupola became a fixture on cabooses,
and was used by all of the men to observe
the train and look for signs of trouble (like
overheated hotboxes).
Also called a doghouse, bone breaker, hack,
hearse, monkey cage, crumm, and snake wagon,
the caboose, like the brakemen and flagmen
who used them, became unnecessary as technology
was developed that performed their jobs just
as well, and for less money.
Air brakes were developed in the 1880s, thus
eliminating the need to turn a wheel.
Electric-powered signals, triggered by track
circuits, made signaling other trains automatic,
and improvements in bearings made the problem
of overheating a thing of the past.
In addition, trains grew longer and the cars
became so tall that viewing much of the train
from a caboose became impossible.
On top of that, computers eventually took
over the paper-handling duties, so there was
no need to store any such paperwork on board.
Rather than a cheerful red car, today’s
trains have small boxes that fit over their
rear couplers to monitor operations.
Tied into the train’s air brake line, these
End of Train devices (EOTs) transmit brake
pressure information to the engineer, who
can also adjust the air brakes with the device.
This is helpful for emergencies, since even
if the train breaks in two, the brakes of
the rear part
can be activated.